the Google nest hub max has all of our
photos from my phone so I seeked a lot
of old throwback lines a lot of phases
oh so problems I was exactly the same
size except for 50 pounds lighter it
looks like you got the nice even print
going on that's coming back in style so
I'm ahead of the game oh yeah there we
go
even though is Halloween I've dressed up
like a cowboy
yeah that's back in the back in the good
old days in high school well you
shouldn't let me wear that in college I
think I was either my senior in high
school or freshman year in college it's
like all right high school will be nice
we'll do the first picture we ever took
together that's back 21 smiling wasn't
cool serious that's Beth in my baller
days I was a monster on the court a
fight plan up with like kids two years
older than me yeah the game face was
legit man if I'd have the tongue got it
look just like I do nowadays yep we got
the footage from that okay sweet we'll
see we'll see it for sure
hey google play Patrick mahomes drone
video on YouTube
okay playing on YouTube I don't got know
where the things going to
[Music]
Oh beat it off
he hit the freakin break and was just
gone yeah you blame him
you ready clothes this is way harder
than it looks all right yep yeah yeah so
I mean we me and Dave got it quickly
yeah you hit the brake on the like the
slant you just took off and I was like
gosh man but then he did exactly the
same thing the next time we got yeah
this is a drone make it oh man oh I got
him